Lando is back baby yeah a little bit  yeah how did it feel to get that call  well you know I I never expected it I  thought I figured you know I did what I  needed to do with Lando I created an  interesting character which has been in  the minds of people for 40 years so I  didn't really expect to be a part of it  again but when I got the call from from  JJ I really and I went down to we talked  and I chuckled a lot because it was an  opportunity to work with somebody that I  really I adore he's a wonderful young  man and I was really looking forward to  having this wonderful creative exchange  with JJ so it's one of the highlights  I've been doing it for 60 years but this  is certainly one of the highlights in my  career I love that so it's safe to say  you're happy with land Ozark in this  movie oh my goodness  there's a kind of death tool that I  think you didn't see before  so I'm looking forward to watching it I  I haven't seen it  [Music]